all right let's start today i guess
we're calling this game do you buy it uh
we've talked before about the people who
have sort of softly come out against
donald trump who were previously
associated with them we've also talked
about the people who criticize him but
then when when it really comes down to
it they go i'd vote for him again
earlier this week william barr trump's
former attorney general said the 2020
election stuff trump was saying was bs
he was out of control and he brought out
a clown show of lawyers and then when
savannah guthrie said okay but if he's
the nominee are you voting for him and
he's like well i'm not going to vote for
a democrat
so that's horrifying and disgusting i
have a different example for you today
this is one of donald trump's former
white house press secretaries stephanie
grisham
my opinion
is that he uh she rather when it comes
to trump
has truly denounced him in a way where
she's saying she's out and here in this
particular clip on the view
uh or no not on the view on some other
show maybe this is the view um she says
he's a con man and i'm sorry and i don't
want people to vote for him what do you
guys think but my point is now i messed
up i am sorry i will say that until the
the end of time but i want to give
people an offering and i'm going to do
everything i can to educate people not
talk down to them educate people about
who he really is that he is a con man
that it is a cult-like thing and that
it's okay to just get off so you would
okay it is the view so um this listen
i'm not saying let's go out and elect
stephanie grisham to anything she's not
running for anything as far as i know
but if we're gonna kind of categorize
these things you know michael cohen who
we've had on the show
he
genuinely has denounced trump fully
and uh is is cooperating to the extent
that he can
to hold trump accountable and i buy that
he he's off the train completely
william barr i mean i think he's trying
to sell books
i think he does recognize trump was nuts
but at the same time he even said i'd
vote for the guy grisham strikes me as
being closer to cohen
than to bill barr with the important
difference that michael cohen has said
i've always been a democrat and i'm back
to being a democrat stephanie grisham as
far as i know is still a republican and
the off-ramp she's talking about is an
off-ramp more than likely
to people like i don't know mitch
mcconnell
mitt romney maybe or who knows what so
i'd put her closer to cohen i do think
she's sincere
but at the end of the day i still don't
want her deciding who the president is
let me know your thoughts what do you
think about her level of sincerity